India's issued a rare official complaint
to the u.s. embassy protesting
Washington's arrest of almost 130 Indian
students who applied to a fake American
College the University of Farmington
supposedly based in the state of
Michigan in fact had no classes no
teachers and was run by undercover
homeland security agents as part of a
push to catch illegal migrants seems US
law enforcement even created a website
for a college and set up a network of
fake recruiters well India's foreign
ministry says these students were misled
students may have been duped into
enrolling in the University we have
urged US side to release them from
detention at the earliest and not to
resort to deportation against their will
and indeed it's being reported that some
of those Indian students did think the
university was genuine
the indictment though says they knew it
was an illegal scheme that would allow
them to stay in the u.s. each of the
foreign citizens who enrolled and made
sure ition payments the university knew
that they would not attend any actual
classes earn credits or make academic
progress towards an actual degree in a
particular field of study
jaqen SAR of the Hindu American
Foundation told us this type of
operation shows that a major flaws in
the immigration system these hundreds of
students have been arrested it seems
like a fake university has been
uncovered that was created by the u.s.
government using US taxpayer dollars so
I believe the u.s. the American people
are going to want to know if this was a
good use of their taxpayer dollars these
types of scams of luring students to
come here only showcases that the
immigration system is broken and
unfortunately we are not seeing the
impetus of the US government to try and
fix it
now we hope that there is a
congressional resolution through through
legislation soon
you